valve is publishing more plagiarized
weapon skins a few weeks ago valve
dropped the brand new Revolution case
and CS go fans were reasonably hyped
since we haven't got a new case in over
seven months unfortunately there were a
couple of problems two of the Skins were
reportedly using stolen artwork the op
doodle lore and the m4a4 temukao in
regards to the op multiple Twitter users
including the original artist vax posted
about the artwork being copied and even
provided examples and well yeah it's a
rip-off Vex successfully filed dmca but
instead of making it a Contraband skin
like the infamous howl valve replaced it
all together that means if you already
unboxed or purchased the doodle lore
it's actually a completely different
skin now as for the M4 temukao things
get a bit more complicated some suggest
that the anime character was stolen but
the artist and those on their side think
otherwise regardless it's all a pretty
big cluster